you weren't the one who bet the five
hundred thousand dollars nope i can
promise you that that's not gonna happen
any time
pocket change for the laissez faire yes
somebody
your buddy mean streets of greenwich oh
no steve young that grew up on the mean
streets of greenwich
you are creating a new generation of
laissez-faire children growing up on the
mean streets of granite that's right
don't don't you dare accuse my kids of
being laissez-faire okay i'm one of
these days i might see you so
no but i'm doing good that was a good
game last night
i mean ugly of course as we know uh
but but never felt like the seahawks
were
in trouble or in danger of losing you
kept going whoa they're really flirting
with danger here
man they could have put this game away a
while ago uh
and i give doug peterson and
philadelphia credit for hanging tough
but
ultimately i think the result was about
what we thought and
the game was kind of the way you would
thought you would think too i mean
seattle's the better football team
on both sides of the football and this
is somewhat of a tough matchup but a
good win for them either way
yeah it never felt like the seahawks
were in serious danger
although when it was 14 nothing
the eagles mount that long drive fueled
by one of the worst
calls of the year are you kidding me the
clear
intentional grounding where carson wentz
was that the play when the ball got
snapped over his head right yes
yes and he goes even deeper right yeah
goes even deeper he's like
40 yards behind the line of scrimmage
doesn't get the ball to the line of
scrimmage
outside the pocket yes but you have to
be outside the pocket and at least get
the ball to the line of scrimmage and
it's okay
if the ball gets to the line of
scrimmage out of bounds it doesn't have
to land in bounds past the line of
scrimmage it just has to get
past the stick and it was obvious
that it didn't get to the stick because
there was a an official standing there
as the ball was caught like two yards to
his left
it didn't get to the line of scrimmage
and then the referee
turns on his microphone and says there
is no intentional grounding on the play
because the quarterback was outside the
puck and got the ball to the line of
scrimmage
isn't that one of the moments where if
you're out river on a 345 park avenue
you mash on that button
i don't care what you're allowed to use
it for and not use it for we see way too
many times
uh we're having a conference here doc
pay no attention to me pressing my
earpiece in so i can hear
someone talking to me from new york
we're actually having a conference here
no they weren't and they should and
and why why are you going to have that
pipeline if you're not going to use it
in that moment
to tell them clearly the ball didn't get
to the line of scrimmage chris
yeah i mean clearly and you're right
that got to a dangerous part of the
football game we got to
14 what was it 14-6 before the half
you know the seattle goes three and out
philadelphia gets the ball
they go down they kick a field goal 14-9
and you're going whoa
yeah they are flirting with danger yeah
the seahawks you know they dropped the
ball early in the game
as we've seen you know with a lot of
football teams you got a chance to put a
team away
then yeah you're you're you you might be
sitting there three quarters later going
whoa we're like in a one-score game and
we've outplayed this football team
you know that first drive of the
football game getting down all the way
to the goal line
dk metcalf not being able to make the
block on barnett
on the fourth fourth and goal that was a
big moment to where
man you apply a lot of pressure on
philadelphia right off the bat and put
pressure on carson wentz and that
offense that's
been underperforming then the next drive
they kind of get stuck in no man's land
right
seattle again and they get to the fourth
down and russell's got nobody open he
tries to scramble and run no first down
and
yeah all of a sudden you go wow
seattle's dominating the football game
but it's 0-0
and that's life in the nfl but credit to
seattle they don't bat an eye they just
continue to battle and fight and do that
and you know they just out uglied the
ugliest team in football
in the philadelphia eagles first drive
of the game though you're inside the
five and i i don't okay you go for it on
fourth and two because
we're all aggressive now we have to be
aggressive aggressive is what we must be
the jet motion touch pass bs in that
spot
you lose five yards and i don't care who
missed a blocker didn't miss a block
that's not the play is that i yeah it's
i hear you i
i know i could only coordinate and i
could only coordinate an offense if my
quarterback was patrick mahomes
but that was just one of those it was
developing it's like what are you doing
no yeah no not not when you have russell
wilson
that's it you get in a spot like that
you
keep the ball in russell wilson's hands
so he can either throw it
or run it you lock into that you got one
option
and if it doesn't work you're done you
keep the ball in russell wilson's hands
you can extend that moment before you
commit to what you're doing whether it's
throw it
or russell wilson sees an opening and he
darts through it for the touchdown sure
listen i'm with you that was my first
thought too man you're taking the ball
or russell wilson there
big play just you know let him drop back
you know throw a ball on rhythm if
nothing's not that you know nothing's
there and then he scrambles and makes a
play does something like that like we've
seen him do a million times
but i'm not gonna fault the play itself
it was there
i think it's something that they felt
like they had
a chance and felt comfortable with
through their film study and all that
and
hey the guy made a good play if i was
gonna fault anything mike i would get
on the old you know the x's and o part
of it
well i know this is dk metcalf and he's
a freak of nature but this is still a
defensive end
that outweighs him by 30 pounds you know
that is not
necessarily fair to ask him hey
block down this guy who's in the
three-point stands and is going to come
off the ball when it says said hut
like you know just just a mad
animal and stop him so we can run that
to me was where the really the problem
was you're asking a receiver to do
something that's not really his bread
and butter
against somebody else's bread and butter
but either way they survived it they
fought through it
and uh russell wilson and d.k metcalf
man
176 yards could have had 250 yards last
night i mean he really could have
he's so special let me just say this and
we'll talk about mcafee in a minute
you're bringing back bad memories
for vikings fans who remember the 2017
nfc championship game because in my
mind the turning point the dagger moment
in that game yeah was when they try to
play
where a tight end was supposed to block
derrick
exactly x's and o's and barnett blasts
past the guy
and stays kingdom fumbles rips the ball
out in case kingdom
and two plays later or something like
that yeah they'll score a touchdown
that was that party's over go home so
yes
the the the xno aspect of it it's not a
video game
it's not an automatic neutralization the
o can't always block the x that's part
of it too and then they go forward on
fourth down again
that's the recipe for disaster if you're
playing
a team that you know isn't bad
and and and maybe the fact that the
seahawks went for it on fourth down
twice in the first quarter
was their own kind of subtle middle
finger to the eagles
i think so we know we know we'll be fine
eventually we can go for it on fourth
down early
we can give you chances we can give you
a shorter field than you would have had
we don't care because you know what
you're never going to score enough
points to beat us through 60 minutes no
i mean i think that's very real mike i
think that's like going into the game
because pete carroll
as you and i both know he's he's a
little bit the other way sometimes to
where you and me come here on a monday
or a tuesday and we're like
you got russell wilson would you go for
it on fourth and two stop
punting and playing defense and doing
that stuff
you know but he he has a style in which
he coaches i respect that and i think he
went into this game
to your point thinking that like hey
we're better than them i have no fear of
their offense
you know our defense has been turning
the corner and playing better as we saw
last night and yeah what's there to be
scared of in philadelphia
what is to be scared i mean the three
most dangerous guys on the field don't
run past four six or four seven
dallas goddard richard rogers boston
scott i mean those are the
those are the go-to guys for the eagles
so yeah who's gonna be scared of that
not the seattle seahawks and i think
that's what led them to some of those
aggressive decisions early on
and and the the the game continued to be
scoreless until the latest
moonshot from russell wilson the center
fielder throw it up
wait for your receiver to go get it and
uh the
the only problem with the play was that
dk metcalf was down
short of the goal line but the 52-yarder
that was that that was the okay
the the seahawks will be fine moment
yeah right you know it was it was
oh well who knows what's gonna happen
they made some dumb decisions they're
leaving the door open for the
the eagles the moment that happened it's
like all right well we know where they
go
this game's going to be well let's keep
watching it because you never know it's
the nfl but
at the same time that was when you knew
that that it was done and
and that ball from russell wilson and
there's the moon shot and there's dk
metcalf decent coverage but it doesn't
matter yeah that's
the 177 yards career high
for dk metcalf following the 160 he had
against the eagles in the postseason
he's got an extra large chip on his
shoulder
about the eagles we'll get into that too
in a few minutes but you know the guy's
dangerous
the guy's special and the guy keeps
getting better and better it seems like
almost every week
as long as they actually you know throw
the ball to him yeah well that's right
and
you know i think we've seen they take it
to heart when they see one on one they
get they're gonna wear it out
they they do their best really i mean i
think they learned that lesson
you know in that cardinals game a way
back that first time where they lost
and hey it's a tough position for darius
slade the philadelphia
eagles i mean he's a really good corner
i mean he's a top 10
corner in football right in that
conversation i'm not going to say he's
top five
but he is that guy and you know i think
just to tell you what the eagles think
of him the fact that they think he could
play man-to-man almost every play
and be on an island with dk metcalf i
think just shows you what they think of
them
but that's just too tall of an order to
ask of just about anybody
that's to where when you get put in that
position that much
listen there's only one guy in my
opinion you know who that is i think
that's jaylen
that's the only guy i think you go okay
you go out there you play and we'll see
where it goes everybody else
i'd like go we gotta dabble in helping
them a little bit we can't just leave
them out there all game long against
this guy
yeah we can't
24 hours after killing the buccaneers
sure we're going man coverage on tyrion
we can't
say oh well at least the eagles tried
it's dk metcalf no you don't go single
coverage on him either
there are certain guys that you don't
leave
in single coverage unless you've got
someone that you know back to the x's
and o's right you can trust
sure to cover the o some o's tougher to
cover
than others and that's what dk metcalf
was last night unless
the eagles were just banking on the
seahawks not throwing it to him
i don't know i don't get it because it's
not like every time he's in single
coverage they feed him the ball
and and as you said jalen ramsey handled
him and he just struggled against the
cardinals
yeah he doesn't get open like he does
against other teams but
last night yeah look at that 13 targets
10 receptions
177 the only thing missing you didn't
score a touchdown but that's okay when
you score 177
in yardage you don't need to score
anything you're setting up
you've done you've done your part in
helping your team score
points yeah that's right he's dangerous
he he helps them in so many other ways
and yeah it's that that's that's a lot
to ask of darius slay in that matchup i
mean there's just no one
no other way to say that that's the way
the eagles play that's why they went out
and got him
and paid him money because they know
they're a man-to-man football team
and i think they realize the last two
years they just didn't have a guy when
they wanted to play
really good offenses that could match up
and do that you know but
really i mean dk matt gaff is so special
and
really just like we saw with mahomes and
tyree kill
i think they left 75 80 yards on the
field
you know drops there was the go route
down the left sideline i want to say
late in the third quarter
where he kind of misplayed the ball and
had darius slay there
uh but either way seattle's offense
found a way and i think the better thing
for seattle when we talk about
super bowl because that's the the class
of team they're in at least in my
opinion the defense for the second week
in a row and i know it's the eagles
offense
but you see moments of them being able
to smother
you know defensive line dominant jamal
adams pops of course
and they seem to get their their crap
together in the back end coverage wise
too here the last few weeks and i think
that's encouraging for them in their
super bowl run here
hard to tell though how that translates
to an actual
good offense and and we'll talk about
that too coming up let's put a pin in
this dk metcalf conversation right
before we do that let's hear from dk
metcalf about the chip that remains on
his shoulder
because the eagles were one of the teams
that decided not to take dk metcalf
and select some other receiver in the
second round of the 2019 draft here's dk
after the game
it's kind of um like coming home uh you
know a place that had a chance to draft
me but
no they didn't so um you know i got to
make them pay
one of the defensive coaches came up to
me and it kind of made me mad that he
was like
um you know i was i was in detroit with
uh megatron but you're not there yet
um you know in my mind i'm not trying to
be megatron i'm trying to be me so
um you know i had a little chip on my
shoulder the whole game
you know d.k metcalf told lisa soldiers
of espn before the game that he
thinks about being passed over so many
times in the draft
25 of his day now that may be an
exaggeration but it clearly is an issue
it clearly is a motivator
it's one of the things that helps second
round receivers become
great when they do become great like a
michael thomas or
a dk metcalf what the hell is jim
schwartz doing
thinking that he's what are you jim jim
what do you don't stir you know there
are certain pots you can stir
there are certain heads that you can get
inside of
don't do it to dk metcalf
and there's dk with the michael jordan
michael jordan took everything
personally that was part of his
greatness and dk metcalf didn't have to
make anything up jordan would sometimes
make stuff
up you didn't have to make it up when
you got jim schwartz coming up to you
talking crap before the game saying
you're no megatron
what's the benefit what are you gonna do
what what's
what's that gonna do to throw dk metcalf
off and
you have to realize it's potentially
going to set him off well wait let me
see that quote again there because
he is he trying to pay him a compliment
by saying that
like he's trying to tell him hey you're
no megatron yet but you're close
you know i don't think he's yeah i don't
think jim schwartz is
i don't think he's trying to stay crap
there well don't say anything
because because when you're dealing with
someone who's got that michael jordan
killer mentality he's going to find a
way
when you already have a guy who is wired
to be pissed off at the team for not
drafting him
anything that he said to him that can
even remotely be construed as a slap
yeah he's going to construe it sure as a
slap yeah
and again i'd like to think jim schwartz
is smart enough to realize you got to
tread lightly on that ground
you have a guy who already is pissed
sorry london apparently they believe it
when i say it they don't bleep but when
chris says
i'm better about it don't unless you're
going to go up to him
and genuflect and kiss his ring and or
his butt
don't even try to say anything that
could be construed because anything you
say
can and will be used against you by the
guy who is looking for anything he can
use
right wrong or otherwise to get himself
in the mindset
to rip your heart out well definitely
and again schwartz should know that
i still fault him even if he was trying
to pay him a compliment
you you have to make it abundantly clear
you have to say you are better
than calvin johnson you have to do
something to leave no doubt
that you're paying him a compliment and
not sticking the knife in him
well i i guess i don't know i'm not
going to nitpick on this i i mean the
day
guys i know apparently we i could tell
i i am but i it proves i'll say this
because i you know jim
i i've been around jim when i was a
tennessee titans there
he's he's not a jerk that way he's not
he's trying to give the guy a real
compliment now like to you said maybe
you got to be careful
because guys like dk metcalf yeah they
should be pissed off
there was like 31 idiot teams who didn't
draft him so he's gonna have one every
now and then
and then he's going wait hold on a
second
you took jj arsego whiteside over me
so i bet you that really pisses him off
i mean
jj arsego whiteside is just a guy
and dk metcalf is the guy we're getting
into just calling him dk
because that's how good he is we don't
need the rest of your name anymore so
it's insane and you know why we're on
the subject
that's what you want to talk we talk
about carson wentz carson wentz
doug peterson doug peterson how about
some of the damn players on the field
i thought brian griese did a great job
last night kind of bringing that point
up
kind of goes under the radar when
everybody talks about philadelphia
you know jj or sega whiteside second
round pick does
nothing jaylen rieger this past year
first round pick
all the great receivers in the draft
taking after him they can't get
diddly squat out of that kid there's
nothing on the team that sits there and
you just
go whoa they should be dominating
you know and i think we've we all
mis-evaluated them a little bit and i
know they've got injuries in that
but when you talk about those two
receivers you talk about al-shawn
jeffrey and desean jackson those are all
howie roseman problems
he signed old guys and took a chance on
guys that were beat up and paid them
money
and i think we just can't forget that
because i know all right right
we don't need to pounce on how he got
enough last night from the guy he once
fired so we don't need to add to that
today the reality is
i just wanted to see the ball three
years ago they were in the playoffs two
years ago and almost got to the nfc
championship game
they were in the playoffs last year yes
it was a horrible division
but there is something wrong as it
relates to
the talent on the family getting the
most out of it and and i suspect that
when they got
jalen rieger this year in round one this
wasn't howie roseman in an ivory tower
saying
this is my guy i don't care
what doug peterson thinks i would
suspect
that it was an organizational right
well that's that's just not what of
course
now now that the no back then lying in
there jumping off of it no
back then this was a thing back then
that this was a thing throughout the nfl
that howie roseman was hot on jalen
rieger
everybody good is he hot but but is he
hot on jalen rigger because that's what
his coach wants
or is that is it just how he roseman
rolls out of bed
and says i want jalen rieger there's a
difference
and i'd like to think that howie roseman
is sufficiently self-aware because he
didn't grow up in the business as a
scout
that he's going to go to his coach and
work with his coach because he's seen
the other side of it
when the coach doesn't work with you
chip kelly what happens there
and we've we've heard about emotional
intelligence and symbiosis and
and i i just i would be surprised if
jalen rieger
was a pick that that howie roseman said
to doug i think there was a lot of stuff
justin jefferson
i know you may want brandon ayuk i know
you may want some of these other guys
but let's go get jaylen
that was a lot it's hard for me to think
well a lot i think a lot of things that
aren't true either
so uh anyway the point is they got and
and you know i made the point last night
they won the super bowl three years ago
all these people saying well it's
ancient history well
is it only the patriots and
the uh the chiefs have won one since
then
there's 30 other teams out there that
would have loved dual won it three years
ago
um including the one that fell victim to
sure no definitely in the nfc
championship game
but there are issues with the eagles and
you know what
when i saw the story over the weekend
that jeffrey lurie the owner of the team
didn't go to the game last week in
cleveland
because he's frustrated with the team
that tells me that people are in trouble
whether it's peterson whether it's
roseman whether it's anyone whether it's
everyone
and even though you got a fairly fresh
lombardi trophy
if the owner's upset nobody's safe
and you know last night for the first
time i just got and maybe it's because
it was
it was a pile drivers and body slams off
the top rope by the guys who were
calling the game because it does
influence how you view the team
um i was starting to think maybe maybe
some people are in trouble with this
eagles organization and
maybe there will be some some heads
rolling when the season ends if not soon
or the way things are going but yeah i i
i mean
there's definitely got to be a
re-evaluation
a wait we got to go back to the drawing
board i don't know if we're on hot seat
territory i'm not
i don't think we are yet i think next
year everybody is
i think next i think you're on notice
right agreed yeah and
again here listen i know i came in
strong there
okay about howie roseman and everything
like that because i got on the receiver
topic and
yeah i just get passionate about players
sometimes he's done a lot of really good
things i understand that
all i was really going off on there is i
was really mad at myself
and just even the media in general
because we always make it about peterson
and wentz peterson and wentz and wentz
and wentz and wentz and i was just
trying to say
it's truly it's totality like you're
saying it's an organization thing
there's a lot of issues here that have
resulted in what we see in crappy
results on the football field and
that's really where i was trying to get
at i think the worst thing that happened
to peterson and wentz was last year when
they were five and seven
and they scraped together seriously
straight wins
with a bunch of no names yeah because
then you're thinking hey they can get it
done with anybody
right they get it done they got it done
and now all of a sudden they can't get
it done and i still don't know what the
issue is
with carson wentz and i don't think
anybody in the organization does so last
night we finally saw
some jalen hurts on the field
although that was clunky too put the guy
out there for two snaps he completes a
pass
and then you pull him off the field on
third down and carson wentz gets sacked
what the hell is that chris yeah well
you know again they're searching for
anything right now
they are and i think they're trying to
tell you and i think the announcers are
trying to tell you jalen hurts is not
ready to run
like the normal offense and and throw
and make those type of decisions
but nonetheless you know i think we're
both we'd like to see
more of a niche in the offense just
because the offense isn't capable of
doing much they just need
something you know and and i would be
one to go no i'd rather see him out
there with carson wentz i think that's
going to put more stress
on a defense and those type of things
too because then you don't know what to
expect
more but either way they dabbled in it
it was clunky
you know i don't know what happened on
the first delay of the delay again or
the the false start
you know it's a different guy in there
different snap count different rhythm
guys panic but yeah i'm with you you'd
like to see a little bit more there
definitely but there's just issues
everywhere hey yeah carson wentz
just as you we saw all the off the
offensive lines not special
all the injuries and you know they're
just they're outclassed more weeks than
not
right now and when you're going to send
the guy out there
and and and you know there was some
confusion during the broadcast as to
what went on because they had to take a
time
out there was a helmet issue yeah the
helmet issue is jalen hurts went out
there with his quarterback helmet on
with the green dot in it
when carson wentz was out there if
you're going to put a second quarterback
out there when you already have your
starter on the field he's got to take a
different helmet
he can't take the helmet that has the
the green dot and the receiver in it
you're not allowed to have two guys out
there hearing what's being said
from the sidelines so that was the
problem or we would have seen more
jamming hurts well what i would say to
that a little bit is just like
why like can we get over that like oh
there's two green dots on the field
that's a different issue
i know it's a different issue i know but
you're totally right it changes you're
right
thou shalt only have one guy on the
field with the green dot helmet you're
exactly right though and i won't i won't
get off topic
they gotta he's gotta stand on the
sideline with the other helmet in his
hand the whole time or somebody had the
equipment guy
and there's an equipment guy always you
know
relegated or assigned to the
quarterbacks at all times you know you
see that guy
quarterback comes off gets the hat puts
a jacket on
you know that's that's his equipment guy
that's the right hand man on the
quarterbacks he's going to be there all
day to make sure you need gloves yo
you need a hand warmer blah blah blah
blah blah they got to have that guy on
duty to hold that extra helmet for for
jalen hurt so that doesn't happen again
let's hear from doug peterson talking
about the use of jalen hurts in last
night's game
[Music]
the plan was to use him when we could uh
the way the game started you know we
just didn't have many opportunities
too many three and a half i don't think
we got a first down until the second
quarter just
we just didn't uh we failed to execute
so it just wasn't uh
um it just wasn't you know in
in the in the cards i guess it will
speak you know early in the football
game but
uh you know no more no less than what we
would uh you know use them each week
it seemed to suggest that lack of
offensive rhythm was why hertz was not
more involved early
but isn't that and like i guess can't
that be
a reason the play hurts more
no and why not
because it's not about one guy you know
we had breakdowns uh
across the board and it doesn't really
matter
you know who's back there the the
mistakes were still going to be made and
and um you know something we got to fix
i really do feel bad for doug peterson
yeah and carson wentz and
because you you they they have been
good the past few years and when it
slips away when it disappears when all
of a sudden it's gone
and nothing you do can recapture it and
i really do feel like the urgency builds
and builds and builds and builds and
we've said all year long it's like
carson wentz is trying in one moment
to validate every decision that the
eagles have ever made
about him trading up to get him second
overall pick
him over falls after the 2018 season big
money for wentz
you can't fix it all you can't rewind
the clock to 2017
2018 2019 in one moment you just have to
grab a shovel and dig
and uh it just feels like they're
digging the hole deeper
there there's there's not going to be
yeah you're right i mean at some point
they're just gonna hit rock bottom and
it's gonna be like okay i mean this this
is what it is
and we have to re-orchestrate reorganize
our football team
it is a shame carson wentz yeah he
doesn't help himself of course as we
know
with some of the turnovers we've seen
all year he does have that to like what
you're saying mike
it's it's the last play of the game all
the time type of feel
that leads to you know reckless plays
and everything there
but where i will continue to defend them
at least to a degree here
is again the support system i it really
is i mean
there's no run game to talk about
there's nothing
the pass game there's nobody that
garners any attention
any shape way or form nobody the seattle
seahawks
can't play man-to-man mike they were
like oh we'll play man-to-man against
this team
we don't care they're not they're like
one of the worst man-to-man teams in
football
but they had no fear of doing it against
the philadelphia eagles i was arguing at
the
they're yelling at the screen a few
times seattle stop being so aggressive
you know but but either way i think that
speaks to it and then when carson wentz
is also your leading rusher
and they have no dillard and no you know
lane johnson
uh and and brandon brooks is out yeah
their team is decimated old
and has some young guys in some new
spots and they're just not ready for
prime time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports